okay so if you're here you probably
watched our breakdown of Technicolor if
not I'll put the link up here somewhere
I wanted to make this video to cover
some of the things that I didn't have
time to put in that video some of the
research and footnotes and also to thank
the people who helped us make that video
in this case that would be Eastman house
they're a museum that you can go to you
can find them online and they were
really generous with their time their
knowledge and also a lot of the images
that you see in the video and I also
want to thank the Smithsonian of course
which let us talk to their curator also
very knowledgeable and get in there and
film that giant Technicolor camera and
the gorgeous ruby slippers got to film
those ruby slippers myself so I think
basically I'm like a legendary Hollywood
cameraman now because I've shot those
ruby slippers
just a theory anyway let's get to it
let's watch the video and I'll tell you
what we had to leave out and what we
really wanted to put in so yeah
obviously this videos centered around
Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz I have to
tell you that I'm a person who believed
some of these misconceptions before I
started making this video I may have
known that it wasn't the first
Technicolor video but I didn't know the
degree to which Technicolor shaped the
movie and I did think that there was
some sort of technological breakthrough
there but it was largely a marketing
breakthrough they really sold this movie
as a Technicolor movie because it costs
them a lot of money to make it that way
but there were other movies before hand
or in contemporaneous production that
also used Technicolor so this an
important thing to clear up to exactly
why it took over the movies too the way
in which the technology shaped the look
of the 20th century in this whole video
just sprang from my curiosity why does
Technicolor look like that and it turned
out to be more complex than I thought
Technicolor movie not even close
you might know that yes oh sorry to slam
the Maryland Science Center here but and
what are you what are you gonna do they
they said it okay so please look at
Barbour flu catchers website because it
shows you how complex all this color
theory is and also how much people who
know about photography care about the
depth and history of their discipline
there are so many little gradations that
are fascinating to look at okay I have
to tell you one thing I left out about
calmus and Comstock before they got into
Technicolor they developed other camera
nerd projects and one of their early
projects was actually a speed camera
like the kind that catches speeders on
the road and apparently it worked this
is the early 1900s
but they weren't able to sell it to any
police departments probably because they
didn't understand it but it could have
been a whole different 20th century if
they'd stuck with that speed camera idea
instead of moving on to Technicolor yes
this is flowers and trees which is so
cool-looking I'm not a gamer myself but
there's this game out called cop head
now that is inspired by the animation
styles of these 1930s Technicolor movies
you should look it up on YouTube because
they have a really good emulation of
this animation style it looks great and
it makes you understand animation better
okay so this is my Technicolor breakdown
this is the full page of that
Technicolor diagram that I showed now
already there's a lot of different
methods so when I talk about to strip
and three strip here I'm kind of
condensing a bunch of different
processes into one most significant step
from to strip two three strip an analogy
that I thought of was if in the year
2100 they were covering the iPhone the
wouldn't cover iphone iPhone 4 iPhone 4s
iPhone 5 iPhone 5s or whatever the
proper gradations are they would just
say there were blackberries then there
were iPhones than there were Android
they would kind of give you the bigger
picture and that's what I'm doing here
with technicolor I'm kind of giving you
the bigger picture of the switch to
three-strip but there were all sorts of
processes within that that you can look
up and see the differences between them
both in the technology and in the
results and so for these simulations it
was fun because in after-effects I went
through and I did actually properly tint
the things with cyan tint the things
with greens and then actually layer them
on top of one another so I didn't just
replace it with the original picture at
the end this is a proper combination of
all those colors and that kind of helped
me get a grasp on a2 to have to do it
the right way that helped me understand
how this stuff actually worked along
with the help of the people that I
talked to yeah so that that little Lego
guys like that generally the key which I
show there
I heard generally it stopped being used
after 1945 one of the reasons they would
use it because because of blurring also
because it was really hard to get the
three strips in exactly the right place
so sometimes they'd be just a little bit
off a micrometer offer you know what we
would call a pixel today off and so a
key could help kind of like settle them
into place lock them into place over
that black and white image to a color
one the set was actually painted sepia
tone so the same Technicolor process yes
I was amazed Ryan that the Smithsonian
told me about this that was the first
time I'd heard about it and thought that
was an amazing piece of trivia there
even though they did have mats at the
time which is what I do here with my my
hand in the little box they painted this
room sepia because that was the easiest
way to use the camera continuously for
the shot
that's just really crazy and you can see
it if you watch it you can see that it's
a different camera filming that scene
here's the gloriously large Technicolor
camera ryan was super smart really
helped me understand this process better
my greatest pleasure though was enjoying
the historical irony of filming this
gigantic camera with my tiny sony camera
you know literally it's this big I'm
using it to film this right now and I'm
filming this thing that the best
filmmakers in the world in history too
had to use and I'm able to film in 4k
grading it will with just this tiny
little camera so it's just amazing to me
and bizarre to get to do that yeah and
these cameras were super loud they had
to really adjust around that
let's Jimmy Stewart clown right there
the press materials say it was always
Jimmy's dream to play a clown
dad I'm Anubha dad about him hadn't
really heard about that movie even
though it's famous but so yeah this is a
great scene Eastman House gave me this
this strip in these prints from singing
in the rain and it was really fun to
match them up with the scenes in the
movie it also shaped the world that they
chose to film
line number three this isn't the real
Dorothy its judy garland's body double
she wore specially designed clothes yes
Bobby Co Shea's she's really cool we
couldn't find a photo that we could
license in time for this video but if
you look her up you can find some
pictures of her testing out different
dresses I think and there's also one of
her with the body double for the
scarecrow and it's it's really fun to
look at and compare because judy garland
is dorothy is so iconic and then you see
this other person who looks a little
like her but isn't her it's really fun
to see so yeah when it the the slippers
were originally silver I know that a lot
of the people who think The Wizard of Oz
is about the fight between the gold and
the silver standard point to these
silver slippers as evidence of that
theory about the work I asked Ryan about
that he he he was sort of uncertain
exactly where that theory is right now
there are some people apparently who
don't believe it
some who do think it's true that it was
about the fight over the gold standard
that was a little too much historical
baggage to weigh in on this video so we
just left it out but you can look it up
and you can find a lot of information
about there so here's Natalie Kalmus
here I showed the credits for Gone with
the Wind she actually fought a lot on
that movie because she wanted more
extreme colors she didn't like the muted
Browns that were being used so she could
definitely be difficult to tangle with
sometimes which I think makes her
interesting because it shows the power
of the Technicolor company that she
could go around and basically tell
directors what to do on their own movies
because Technicolor was that powerful
and using color was that new that they
were you know ready to believe her power
Technicolor had its own processing
facilities and its own camera crew that
continued Natalie and Technicolor really
endured for a while
ultimately it was ease but it was also
expensive the process that doomed the
traditional process that we recognized
and that we described here it was just
really pricey to process these films to
do that dye transfer process and so the
company changed Technicolor is
definitely still around today but it is
a different company and it doesn't use
that three-step process there are some
minor exceptions of when the three-strip
process has been used after the
Godfather Part two which is about to
come up here there it is so after that
there were some minor exceptions of like
revivals or restorations in which they
did do it through strip process but for
the most part it's gone so it's fair
enough to say that it doesn't exist okay
yeah and then today we have this whole
world of digital color grading besides
me complaining about the dust clouds of
trapcode particular plugin in stranger
things it was kind of good at start you
know brother where art thou and then in
the Aviator Martin Scorsese actually
graded the scenes digitally to echo the
Technicolor process that was used in the
year in which the movie was set so he
has in the early scenes of the movie he
has a to strip looking thing in the
later years he has a three strip looking
thing - my modern eyes it doesn't look
like they did that great a job with it
but that's up for your judgement whether
you think it really accurately simulates
the Technicolor look I think because
Kalmus wasn't there and the Technicolor
company wasn't there
it's more of an homage than an exact
emulation and yeah and that's it I've
talked through the end of the video but
you know also brought us forward to this
world of digital color grading which is
what exists today it's what I'll use on
this video and it's very different so
yeah I just wanted to make this video to
kind of get into some of the things that
we had to leave out the world of
Technicolor is way more complex than
this and this was ten minutes long so
the outro to that video was me kind of
talking through why this video had to be
so long because I went in and I said I
want to just like
use After Effects to show people how
three-strip and to strip worked and that
ended up being a chunk of it but it was
way more complex than that which is
really cool it's not just a
technological story it's a cultural
story of this company that had a lot of
power and these people who were learning
how to use color and that's why I think
makes it interesting so thank you for
watching please take this opportunity no
doubt more on Technicolor visit barber
fluke Rogers website visit Eastman House
both in person and online wood at
whatever you can do and if you can't do
that if you aren't interested in
learning anymore Technicolor details
look up one of these old movies and just
marvel at them
check out singing in the rain see The
Adventures of Robin Hood or look up some
of the old cartoons one of the slides
that I have in there is from a Woody
Woodpecker cartoon that was in
Technicolor and they're gorgeous they
really do have a unique look and a
unique use of color that is just
wonderful to hang out with for a few
hours so thanks for watching and
hopefully you'll enjoy it